je sais pas ce qu'il faut en attendre on
aurait pu imaginer que
[Musique]
constitutionnellement le gouvernement
tous les mois son chef annonce au
parlement les mesures qu'il va prendre
là il faut attendre de regarder la
télévision à 20h
tout ça devient très à quelle heure 18
heures voyez bon c'est quand même très
paradoxal je veux dire cet évitement ce
contournement perpétuelle de la
représentation nationale est quelque
chose qui devient préoccupant je veux
dire il n'y a plus de conseil des
ministres il ya un conseil de défense il
ya plus de parlement celles 20 heures ou
le 18 heures qui sert maintenant
bon je sais pas jusqu'où ça ira mais
tout ça est inquiétant effectivement
vous parliez du conseil de défense qui
se réunit pratiquement toutes les
semaines pour décider des nouvelles
mesures sanitaires c'est un mauvais
signe pour la démocratie ce
fonctionnement écoutez il faut prendre
des décisions
il ya une situation qui est difficile
sur le plan sanitaire sur le poids
économique pour sociale raison de plus
pour que le gouvernement s'appuie sur
les représentants des citoyens c'est à
dire sur l'assemblée et sur le sénat et
qui peuvent partager beaucoup des
décisions là il ya des choix qui tombe
d'en haut qui sont décidées de façon
unilatérale et confidentiel puisque
c'est confidentiel défense en conseil de
défense et personne est informé en nous
qu'on sent quelques passages télévisés
on va regarder la télévision
alors sur les sujets auxquels on va
porter attention durant cette séance de
cette conférence de presse du premier et
bien il ya la question des commerces il
est question également du protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles vous attendez
un changement de stratégie sur ces deux
points qu'il faille resserré peut-être
un peu sur les établissements scolaires
c'est possible là encore il faut le
faire avec les élus puisque je vous
rappelle quand même que les collèges
dépendent des départements les lycées de
la région et les écoles primaires des
communes
donc ça nécessiterait évidemment mais je
pense que monsieur blanc caire le fait
relativement bien en revanche pour le
reste
vous savez on a assez peu de contacts
avec le gouvernement c'est encore une
fois des décisions unilatérales qui
tombe et qu'on doit appliquer peut-être
que certaines sont indispensables et
nécessaires
elle serait je pense mieux acceptée si
elle était partagée c'est quand même des
décisions qui concernent les territoires
et donc les sénateurs qui sont censés
représenter ces territoires ils n'ont
pas d'information non d'accord c'est
vous allez vous étonner de cette
situation écoutez c'est pas c'est pas un
étonnement c'est même extrêmement
préoccupant on est en train de tuer le
commerce en france je veux dire c'est
quand même considérable ça sert à rien
de voter des lois de revitalisation des
centres bourgs
quand on ferme les commerces pendant la
moitié de l'année et que la plupart
d'entre eux ne pourront pas réouvrir
sans préjudice du de la qualité fonds de
commerce
qu'est ce qu'il va devenir après
quelques mois de fermeture est avec un
bilan proche de zéro donc on est en
train d'anéantir non seulement j'allais
dire une partie de notre tissu
économique mais également humain
songez à toutes ces familles qui sont
concernées et puis ce que représente un
commerce dans un village une petite
commune la moitié des communes de france
36000 ont moins de 500 habitants
on demande pas de réouvrir le printemps
ou le bon marché mais vous pouvez
réouvrir des petits commerces de
province qui sont qui constitue une
animation et qui vendent du pain des
cigarettes qui font bistrot et qui sont
indispensables dont seulement à la vie
locale mais également au lien social
merci beaucoup avait lancé pour votre
réaction on imagine
[Musique]